Hugo plans to buy packs of baseball
cards until he gets the card of his
favorite player but he only has enough
money to buy at most four packs suppose
that each pack has probability 0.2 of
containing the card Hugo is hoping for
let the random variable X be the number
of packs of cards Hugo buys here is the
probability distribution for X so it
looks like there is a 0.2 probability
that he buys 1 pack and that makes sense
because that first pack there is a 0.2
probability that it contains his
favorite players card and if it does at
that point he'll just stop he won't buy
any more packs now what about the
probability that he buys two packs well
over here they give it a 0.16 and that
makes sense there's a point 8
probability that he does not get the
card he wants on the first one and then
there's another point 2 that he gets it
on the second one so 0.8 times 0.2 does
indeed equal 0.16 but they're not asking
us to calculate that they give it to us
then the probability that he gets three
packs is 0.12 eight and then they've
left blank the probability that he gets
four packs but this is the entire
discrete probability distribution
because Hugo has to stop at four if even
if he doesn't get the card he wants at
four on the fourth pack he's just going
to stop over there so we could actually
figure out this question mark by just
realizing that these four probabilities
have to add up to one but let's just
first answer the question find the
indicated probability what is the
probability that X is greater than or
equal to two what is the probability
remember X is the number of packs of
cards Hugo buys I encourage you to pause
the video and try to figure it out
so let's look at the scenario as we're
talking about probability that our
discrete random variable X is greater
than or equal to two well that's these
three scenarios right over here and so
what is their combined
find probability well you might want to
say hey we to figure out what the
probability of getting exactly four
packs are but we have to remember that
they all add up to 100% and so this
right over here is zero point two and so
this is zero point two the other three
combined have to add up to zero point
eight zero point eight plus zero point
two is one or a hundred percent so just
like that we know that this is zero
point eight if for kicks we wanted to
figure out this question mark right over
here we could just say that look have to
add up to one so we could say the
probability of exactly four is going to
be equal to one minus 0.2 minus 0.16
- 0.128 I get one minus point two minus
point one six minus point one two eight
is equal to zero point 5 1 2 is equal to
0.51 to zero point five one two you
might immediately say wait wait this
seems like a very high probability
there's more than a 50% chance that he
buys four packs and he has to remember
he has to stop at four even if on the
fourth he doesn't get the card he wants
he still has to stop there so there's a
high probability that that's where we
end up there is a little less than 50%
chance that he gets the card he's
looking for before that point